here on the range were at the other end
of the range that hasn't stopped some of
the big hitters from trying to hit into
us he's Jim Furyk won 17 times on tour
also won a major Ryder Cup captain and
here to assess greatness or at least
reasonable facsimile so if you were
gonna say who looks like a golfer
out of those four just looks just looks
like a golfer like if you were picking a
partner this is like being like I'm back
in third grade and I'm drafting yeah I
got you gets a little scrawny get it
yeah so who do you got I'm going on the
end right here you never want to look
like this but when you play in a program
okay how do you survive you don't want
him on your channel no no he's got to
move like here he's trying to Paulie
cares more about looking like a glow
we'd like to dress like a golfer wait
what's skateboard shoes but when you're
in a pro and you're a pro am the number
one question you get is what from the
amateur what's the most common mistake
you see all your amateurs make okay and
there's probably two or three that I
would say rough the bat most hammers
have a very poor grip so their contact
with the club is bad they're afraid of
slicing it they like to get you know
hands on the grip real strong as I feel
like that's gonna help them square the
club face but you know having a bad grip
you're probably gonna have a bad golf
swing to start with second one I'd say
most amber's want to put the ball too
far back in their stance right they're
afraid to hit the ball fat they're free
to the ground first
so they put the ball real far back in
their stance but that causes a lot of
problems too it caused a lot of reverse
pivots and in issues and then three most
amateurs they're trying they never have
enough Club in their hand right if if
it's between eight or nine and I think I
can get in
probably those three things but could
you teach your swing I wouldn't want to
to be honestly the hello cuz your dad
taught you your swing didn't he well yes
he taught me the game he's my teacher
but he didn't teach me how to take the
club up and outside rerouted coming that
was very natural and my dad was smart
enough as a teacher that I'm not real
mechanical like my wife Tabitha fixes
everything fix anything I'm not
mechanically inclined and I play the
game by feel and my swing to me feels
kind of straight back and straight
through I realize it's not my dad was
smart enough to realize that we couldn't
change that and we had to work on my
basic fundamentals like everyone else
you know my my grip my posture all
everything am I set up how we're gonna
return the club to the same position
every time but he let me do it my own
way and I'm thankful for that because I
would have struggled if I tried to make
everything more conventional was a Gary
McCord who had the description of your
swing parody Oh was ferdi the man trying
to kill a snake in a phone book David
David's a friend and loved the guy to
death and some people thought I'd be
offended by that I thought it was funny
I mean it is funny witty funny using
that do you think he could give us one
line that describes each of our swings
after seeing them oh no here's something
golf terminology mmm they're not well
versed right in the game usually you can
pick up on a possible handicap range
slightly but just there they need lines
like I gave them don't throw up on your
shoes okay you know which is an
expression I've been told before never
up never in yeah what are the ones that
are just that that could help them if
they ever get into a group like when
Nick Faldo comes by they can say
something to Faldo like if you have a
guy that wants to hit a ball really hard
and tell me you know what are you you go
ahead and you crush when I let the shaft
out on that one okay what else
oh hey - Chloe hit it stiff I hit a
close has good to hit it stiff hit it
tight stiff is tight what if I said I'm
gonna hit a precocious little 8-iron
you know precocious yeah not to bother
anybody three you need said I'm a
three-fingered 8-iron okay your finger
maybe gonna take a little awful off the
three fingered a night will soft fade
but that's that's not a little cutty
sark oh okay see there you go that's
great
all right I like alcohol involved in
this what's the craziest thing you've
thought of over the ball it's amazing
what can go through your mind no the
problem every other sport you react
right basketball guy got the pass
someone's in his face he throws when
it's all reaction you know and in golf
you get forty seconds and you're lining
up and you're standing over the ball and
it's not moving and you might play some
tricks on you there so I don't know I
mean there's times where I'm out there
with a wedge in my hand and I'm thinking
that I you know I'm gonna hit it past
the pin and draw it back and try to give
it a chance to go in from a hundred
yards and there's times where I'm that
far from the hole and I've missed a
bunch of putts that day and I'm thinking
oh god you know don't look like an idiot
but you haven't gone up there and got
over the ball and just wondered about
the kids at home dinner sounds nice
tonight like yeah you've gotten a little
bit sideways there absolutely everyone
does everyone I would cuz I don't know
if I could focus that long
yeah it's stuff like the idea that Ben
Hogan's stayed focused for four and a
half hours and never left it's difficult
you get a guy like Lee Trevino who he's
yapping he's talking or Peter Jacobsen
in there yucking it up with everyone but
when the light goes on they can sit down
for 10 seconds really focus and hit a
shot and then they get out of that and
they go back to yucking it up and having
fun that you have to be kind of will to
kind of turn it on and turn it off turn
around what was it like the first time
you played with Nicholas
just kind of an you know dream come true
but I'll say this the first time I ever
got to play with Jack was at Doral his
son Gary was playing and Ernie else so I
want to say I think it was me and Gary
player me and Jack played Gary and Ernie
yeah and Jack drove it by us on the
first hole so now he's he's throwing and
he starts chirping I'm not gonna talk
smack
I was stuck really like Jack Nicklaus
and then it's you know at the end of the
day is the best ever so we talk smack
you can but by talking back to Jordan or
LeBron I mean you're kind of split were
you did you play with Arne I've only
played with Arne one okay only played
Arnie once I got to play of them it uh
it's a Fred Meyer challenge so yeah John
Houston and I played with with Peter and
Arnie and so uh you know a blast the
blast but when you play like you're not
Arnie is different than Jack cuz Arnie
like Arnie's just he looks like a movie
star out there oh yeah I mean he's just
he's got the short sleeve shirt and
smoking heaters
whereas jack is a little bit different
palms with everyone he was an
unbelievable in bass that's tough on
himself I mean Jack you know I remember
him being at the memorial he's 64 years
old or whatever you know 62 he's playing
the memorial from the back tees and he
comes in and shoots 74 and I saw hey
Jack how'd you play wow I played
terrible dinos 74 I was thinking you'll
take that no and I didn't get the no
Arnold as well but obviously the two of
them we're all you know living this
dream and you know having having a
career in golf because of the two of
them and what they did for the game what
they did for the PGA Tour and the
decisions they made when when the PGA
Tour kind of broke from the PGA of
America they made decisions that weren't
better for them they made decisions that
were better for the game of golf and for
the tour in general and we have a lot to
thank them for what do you think when
you see these guys these younger guys
they're amazed where they hit it they're
amazing I got to play with Cameron champ
last year and he might be a longest
hitter on tour
speed is unreal I mean the speed is
absolutely incredible and the game's
change in the game's evolving and it's
played in a different fashion and it's
it's fun to watch honestly I mean I
don't want to be that grouchy old man
that you know on the Champions Tour
saying back in my day it's fun to watch
I mean they're amazing at what they do
and they come to the tour at a much
younger age than my generation did ready
to win ready to compete and it's
phenomenal it's good still I mean I'm
kind of to be out here I'm 48
I'm still at you're playing against kids
that are young enough to be my children
it's fun for me it's fun for me to get
to know them but uh you know I'm still
trying to compete and get it in there
every once in a while how long did it
take to get over the Ryder Cup
ah well when you say get over you have
to define get over I'm still not over
well I was wondering you know that's
that's the game of golf you know I've
lost a lot of events down the stretch
and big moments in golf and this game
kicks you in the tail will be you're not
playing it's different when but as a
captain that's my team those are my guys
you know it's my responsibility as a
captain to to give them every chance to
win that event and we weren't able to do
it as a group and you know I yeah I'm
gonna be bummed about that forever but
you know in this sport you you move on
yeah I'm excited now to kind of be back
playing a little bit you know last two
years I wasn't able to as much with with
injuries and I spent a lot of time on
the Ryder Cup but I'm happy to be out of
here and play and there's events in my
mind like 98 masters drives me crazy a
couple US Opens you know sick ro7
2012 and Vincent it stings till this day
and the Ryder Cups at the top of that
list what was the one that really stung
individually probably the US Open it I
went to club you know had to lead with
three or four holes to go and hooked it
real bad lay off the 16th tee made a
bogey on a par-5 didn't birdie the par-5
17th kind of butchered 18 you guys your
memories are incredible I remember the
bad ones
only have like three or four to remember
that's the problem
all right I'm gonna see if you can beat
the dinette in closest to the pin okay
your blindfold up you get any closer
points for hitting someone did okay so
your eyes are shut
yeah and then the dinettes will then try
to beat you closest do you want to take
a couple practice my goodness look at
the grip on this yeah that's mine guys
still Bryson - sham no - yeah I know
that's mine but that's a man so that's
probably why it's like a groan I need to
close a grown-ass man yeah you need to
close your eyes under system yeah and we
and I trust you I mean Pennsylvania guy
Midwest guy all right they're open now
okay I'll shot him before all right here
we go shut oh I fatted it really bad
where'd it go okay you got another one
now you're in trouble okay okay let me
practice
here we go all right closed
I hit a solid where is it little right
Oh pin I though all right boy want to
take the loss early would you play at
that is at a hundred nights shorter than
amethyst and is there a chance I'm
better if I close my house 80-ish you in
the way of a camera here it's probably
better if the camera doesn't show this
oh Jesus all right one more pawn that
wasn't bad I didn't notice Jim isn't
offering any critiques here there's too
much to work email what exercise now
there you go Hague okay okay all right
you know what are you I think I met that
one I think think it's too mean either
one should win to be honest with you
look we got to get on the green to win
oh yeah I'm out that's what you're
saying yeah I just changed the rules
once I'm in a running all right
scold it one more seat they say you're
our player hater the kind of it yes shad
I got it yeah well you haven't seen the
other guys all right all right McLovin
right where I usually put it our lines
over six right now yeah
this isn't good yeah Jim definitely put
the blindfold back on the mental
blindfold now this is the guy you were
gonna pick I guess I just went for the
the tall thin guy yeah yeah I can kill
it it's not in the way you want
Oh too bad it's gonna be a little long
I've been all right it's II just don't
know you got one more min Clements nice
y'all are definitely better than you you
said no we're not no they're not no it's
the ball you don't want to plant the
seed here the seed is planted I still
don't understand getting up and down
well you gotta get up to the hole get
down I'll have to do that every day guys
let's let Jim soak this one okay yeah
just just enjoy this one okay like this
face
that's my practice that's a practice
swing a lie it's a practice swing
alright hey yeah that's a base hit down
don't they on the third base line well
not honor the yeah alright stand closer
there you go
I'm up Jim safe no good good oh man he
got in between the shortstop so what
kind of handicapper you carry on the
green as I did what would you play off
of right now angle digits no no probably
a 12 or so
I haven't played so that's the problem
you know what probably should have lost
the gloves a little more feel this is
for the victory lap and the ladies there
we go catch a piece oh right the same
spot yeah that's I don't know what we
accomplished here today
Oh 412 yeah we wouldn't be picked for
the Ryder Cup - yeah thank you for
coming by now I appreciate it it's fine
four more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]